Paul uh you know staying as he uh has
rightly said look musicians have to make
a living they have to be paid so what
are Pandora what are Spotify doing are
they doing anything in response to what
Taylor Swift had said earlier yeah I
think what I think as sting mentioned I
think what this is going to do it's
going to bring I think the streaming
services and the artist Community
together a little bit more and talk
about really what the royalty rate
should be I mean the artists are being
paid by streaming services I think it's
just a question of are they being paid
enough and he says Equitable so what
does that mean uh more I think I think
he's saying just simply more for the
artist um and so what's happening in
music consumption today uh people aren't
even owning music anymore via iTunes
Apple just reported a decline in their
iTunes business for the F uh last
quarter so people aren't even owning
they're just streaming it so they're
kind of renting music uh so the model
shifted yet again from owning physical
albums to owning uh digital uh songs to
actually now just renting them so you
know again as sting mentioned you know
the industry has to evolve and I think
the artist Community has to simp police
say we need to really pay more attention
to what we're getting paid by the
streaming service you know another older
artist gu Brooks actually just came out
with some statements on Taylor Swift as
well and uh we have a quote from what he
said he said look uh quote song
songwriters are hurting so I applaud
Miss Taylor Swift and I applaud everyone
for standing up so it's similar to what
you just heard from sting right but you
know it begs the question Paul you know
you've got older established artists
who've made millions and millions of
dollars like G Brooks like Sting uh The
Beatles
uh Peter Gabriel by the way the latter
two who've decided not to let their
cataloges be streamed on on Spotify you
know should these older artists be
taking stronger stands because they've
got more leverage I think so I mean I
think um clearly you know if if the
Beatles as an entity or if some of these
big bigger uh artists were to come out I
think would clearly raise the the
conversation but if you think about it
Taylor Swift is actually one of the most
uh popular uh singer songwriters on
Spotify she actually you know that this
is her audience uh so when she makes
takes a stand it really resonates
throughout the world of streaming music
Asos right exactly so you know I think
the music industry artists in particular
are saying listen we do not want to
repeat the mistake we made 10 or 15
years ago with iTunes where arguably the
music industry really lost control of
the content lost the ability to really
monetize the content in the digital
world and now they see the business
going to streaming and I think they're
just saying listen before this gets too
big too quickly we want to have a big
seat at the table and and you know
really talk about what is an equitable
you know uh split of the fees I know
it's the term Equitable right it's up
for interpretation negotiation yes all
right Paul thank you so much Paul
Sweeney of Bloomberg intelligence